Down here there's a message
informing the user about which item
they've chosen.
In this case,
we haven't selected anything yet, so
it assumes we're starving and
tells us to pick something.
If I pick something to eat
like strawberry pudding,
the message changes to remind
me which item I've selected.
Now how does Backbone
handle monitoring events?
In app.js we have a view for
the SelectedItem message.
Just like before we get the template
from the DOM, convert it to a string,
and pass it to underscore's
template function.
These buttons are part
of a MenuItemView, and
that's where the button and the
SelectedItem message are wired together.
This is where we set up the events for
each menu item.
When something with a class
of SelectedItem is clicked,
JavaScript will call the selectItem
function which is right here.
Backbone creates a record of all
the events it needs to listen for.
It keeps track of everything that needs
to happen when that event actually runs.
And when the event occurs, it triggers
all the code that needs to run.
We're going to look at Backbone's
on function in isolation,
this way we can really
focus on how it works.
Let's first create an empty object.
Now we'll take this empty object and add
in all of Backbone's event functions.
Since it has Backbone's on method,
I can now set up an event for
this object to listen for.
Finally, I'll trigger that event and
pass it some data.
Backbone took this string and
passed it to the callback function and
logged out this message.
Let's dive into on and
see how it's doing this.